abone ol
[Müzik]
Herkese
merhabalar ben bu işe Kondakçı sosyal
medya üzerinden spor sağlıklı beslenme
ve motivasyon konulu içerikler
üretiyorum bütün bu hikaye Benim 16
yaşında kurduğum Bir Hayal ile başladı
Aslında imkansız olarak gördüm bir
hayaldi bu asla ulaşamayacağını
düşünüyordum ama
yani ulaştıktan sonra kişiliğim
üzerindeki birçok etkisi oldu
kişiyim üzerine hayatım üzerine çok
farklı etkileri oldu ve beni bambaşka
bir insan haline getirdi Bu Hedef
yani ulaşmak benim için gerçekten çok
çok özel bir şey de aynı zamanda bu
hedefimi Ulaş ulaştığım için şu anda
milyonlarca
insana bulaşabiliyor milyonlarca insana
ilham olabiliyorum binlerce insanın
hayatına dokunabiliyorum Bu da benim
için çok özel bir Ben kendime bir iş
olanağı yaratmam aynı zamanda insanlara
ilham olmam benim için gerçekten çok
güzel bu hikaye nasıl başladı bu e
hayalim nasıl şekillendi ondan birazcık
bahsetmek istiyorum aslında ev Yani
bütün bu hikaye ben 16 yaşındayken 15
yaşındayken Amerika'yı tek başıma gitmem
LV orada yabancı Amerikalı bir ailenin
yanında yaşamla dört ay kalmam da
başladı onlar Tabii ki çok fazla böyle
yemek kültür evde yemek yapma kültürleri
yoktu evet Sürekli Dışarıdan yemek
yiyorlardı Ben de tabi dört ay boyunca
onlarla yaşayınca sürekli Ya tabi yemede
dikkat etmiyorum kendim yemek yapmayı
bilmediğim için de sırası Dışarıdan
yemek zorunda kalıyorum Efe Suriye'ye 4
ayın sonunda İstanbul'a döndüğümde Ben
15 kilo civarında almıştım Dört ayda
yani öyle bir yemek yeme tarzı dişinin
yani de ailecek yemek yemeyi seven
insanlar olduğumuz için kendimi direkt
böyle Herhalde yemeği vermiştim o
dönemde çok güzeldi Çok mutluyum ama
sonrasında Tabii ki acısı çıktım Ey
Buraya ilk döndüğünde havalimanında
Ailem beni gördüğünüz böyle şok
geçirmişler ama sağ olsun Hiç belli
etmediler bana tabi ise dönemleri 15 16
yaşında olduğum için arkadaşlarım
birazcık acımasızdı ve çok dalga
geçiliyordu benimle okula gidiyordum ve
okuldan her gün dönerken ağlıyordum
kendimden artık böyle Maalesef ki nefret
eder hale gelmiştim ne yapacağımı da
bilemiyorum ailem tabi çok üzülüyordu
benim böyle üzülmeme O yüzden beni
Aslında en iyi diyetisyenlere
gönderdiler Ben elimden gelenin en
iyisini yapmaya çalıştım ama olmuyordu
Yani bir şekilde tutunamıyorum ve bir
şey eksiktim bir süre bu şekilde devam
ettim denedim
bıraktım tekrar başladım yine bıraktım
Bir süre böyle tutulmaya çalıştım bu ama
dediğim gibi birşey eksiktim Yine bir
gün kabul edeyim kıyafet deniyorum ve
Tabiki kıyafetleri yakıştırıyorum
kendime
kalbimde kıyafet denerken bir anda yan
kabinde birinin 10 kilo verdi bir kitap
okuduğunu ve 10 kilo verdiğini duydum
Hemen kabinden Kendimi dışarı attım ve
hangi kitap olduğunu sordum yani o an o
Neyse bana kilo verdirecek olan şey
neyse onu yapmalıydım ve öğrenmeliyim
nasıl yapıldığını kendisi bana bir kitap
önerdi ve ve ben direk o kitabı alarak
okumaya başladım Koç tabi okuduktan
sonra anladım ki aslında Çok da zor bir
şey yokmuş yani protein ne olduğunu
öğrendim karbonhidratı ne olduğunu
öğrendim vitaminleri Mineralleri hangi
besinlerde olduğunu bunları öğrendikten
sonra ne yapmam gerektiğini bildikten
sonra A çok daha kolaymış Aslında
yapılabilir birşeymiş diyerek daha emin
bir şekilde başladım bu sürece ve ben bu
sürece başlar başlamak anladım ki o ne
olmuş bir şeyler ve direk mesela
başladıktan sonra kaptırıp gittim ve
yaklaşık 12-13 kilo kadar verdim sonra
tabii ki motivasyonunuz düşebilir işte
çıkabilir tekrardan motivasyon zaten
sabit giden birşey değildir En sürekli
dalgalanır ya da işte azalır yükselir bu
değişken bir şey olduğu için tutun Ama
ya biliyorsunuz bazen böyle boşluğumuzda
gelebiliyor ve bıraka biliyorsunuz
Belediyesi bıraktım o bıraktığım dönemde
zaten arkadaşlarım şeydi yani bana karşı
bırakmamın sebebi de söyleyeyim mi
lisedeyim arkadaşlarım çikolata yiyorlar
bana böyle hani canımı çektirmek için
ellerinden gelen her şeyi yapıyorlar
tabela kötülüklerinden değil ama gençlik
diyelim ra böyle cehaleti diyelim böyle
arkadaşına destek olmak değil mi eğlence
amaçlı yaptıkları için de E tabi bende
değil bıraktım Sonra bırakınca bayağı
uzaklaştım tekrar kilo almaya başlayınca
dedim ki bu Çubuk bu şekilde o bu ve
Esen'in tekrardan başlaman lazım şimdi
daha önceden ben bu sürece girdiğim için
başladığım için kendimden çok birazcık
daha emindim yani yapabileceğimi
biliyordum başlarsam ve tekrardan
sarıldım diyete ve bu sefer bayağı kilo
verdim Hatta hedefin çok çok daha
üstünde verdim E şöyle Aslında ilk
başlarda hedefinizin bence çok yüksek
olmaması gerekiyor hedefinizi ne kadar
ufak tutarsanız o kadar daha Bence
tutuna biliyorsunuz Bu sürece diye
düşünüyorum yani bunu sadece kilo verme
süreci olarak düşünmeyin Aslında bunun
Ben bir başarı hikayesi olduğunu
düşünüyorum Çünkü bir hedefim vardı Bir
hayalim vardı ve o hayale Aslında
ulaşmak benim çok daha güçlü bir
kişiliğe sahip olmama sebep oldu çok
daha kendini güçlü hisseder oldum Ne
tutunursan artık başarabilirim
yapabilirim gibi hissediyor duş O da
kişiliği üzerinde bu etkilerini
hissediyorum şöyle Size bir fotoğraf
fotoğrafımı göstermek istiyorum neydim
ne oldum niye böyle yani bu sürecin
benim için bir iş potansiyeline [ __ ]
iş fırsatına dönmesinden de birazcık
bahsetmek istiyorum
ben üniversiteden mezun olmaya çok
yakınken
pandemi daha yeni patladı dönemlerdi
Tabii ki böyle hani yemek ve olan
ilişkimden bu evde oturuyorum işte spor
artık yapamıyorum eskiden bu arada yani
spor çok severek yapardım sporda Hatta
Amerika'da kilo aldım dönemde yüzerdim
de her yüzüyordum ama o kadar yemeye
gerçekten spor fayda etmediği noktalar
olabiliyor yani yemenize de beslenmenize
de dikkat etmeniz gerekiyor Eğer kilo
verme hedefin değilseniz yani spor
hayatımda olmasına rağmen kilo doğal bu
döndüğüm zaman da tanemi değer kilo
almaya başladım tekrardan Neden Çünkü
spor yapamıyordum spora gidemiyorum
yemek yemeye vermiştim kendime
üniversiteden yeni mezun olacağım ne
yapacağım belli değil böyle bir
çıkmazdayım ne yapacağımı bilemiyordum
ve İçimden bir anda dedim ki ne zaten
YouTube içerikleri arada bir üretiyordu
mevsim yani bana bir motivasyon olsun
ben hani güzelliği savaşım evde kendi
kendime spor yapmaya başlayayım dedim
çünkü yani salondan aletler ile bir
yapıyordum bir şeyler ama ton Sen olarak
daha önce hiç kendi kendime spor
yapmıyordum ve orada spor yapmaya
başladım kendi kendime sonra YouTube bir
tane bir çektim böyle bir kilo verme
sürecim oldu ve işte yani biri kendime
karın antrenmanı çıkardım onun sayesinde
böyle pek benim olunca insanlarda böyle
görüntüler bir milyon oldu bir anda
video insanlarla görünce Abur çevre
nasıl yaptın bu karın kaslarını video
Paylaş diye böyle ısıt Eve gelince ben
de kendini acil Anne karnım canımı
paylaştığım hiç böyle yüksekliklere
büyüklere ulaşacağını düşünmeden ve bir
şu anda o video dört buçuk milyona
ulaştı Ben de insanlar benden sporla
ilgili işte beslenme ile ilgili
içerikler beklediği için işte sağlıklı
beslenme ile ilgili sporcu beslenmesi
eğitimi aldım iki tane pilates
eğitmenliği aldım yani madem insanlara e
yönelik bir şey yapacağız en doğrusunu
yapmak gerekir diye düşündüm yani sosyal
medya tarafı benim için şu anda çok
güzel bir şekilde ilerliyor insanlara ve
motivasyon verebilmek İnsanların
hayatına dokunabilmek benim için
gerçekten çok çok özel bir şey
aramızda zaten çok farklı bir bağ
olduğunu düşünüyorum ben takipçilerimle
şöyle Onların bir fotoğraftır
fotoğraflarını koyamıyorum aslında bana
yüzlerce bir fotoğraftır fotoğrafı
geliyor bana yazdıkları mesajlardan
böyle birkaç alıntı koymak istedim ben
bu koymak istedim yani bu bağ gerçekten
benim için paha biçilemez çok güzel bir
şey zaten şöyle de olduğuna inanıyorum
ben
motivasyon vermek insana gerçekten
motivasyon almak başka birinden çok çok
kolay olabiliyor yani motivasyon
alabilirsiniz ama bu işte Aslında en
önemli olan şey istikrar yani İnsanlar
da aslında benim o istikrarı mı görüp
kendilerine kendileriyle bağdaştırmalar
ı sayesinde ben bunu olduğuna inanıyorum
Hadi ben onları motivasyon veriyorum ama
şöylede bir nokta var motivasyon
başkasından alabilirsiniz ama
gün sonuna geldiğinde ya da gün
başladığında o yataktan çıkarken Siz tek
başına sınız kimse yok yanınızda yani o
istikrarı sizin sağlamanız gerekiyor
Kendi kendinize sizin vermeniz gerekiyor
günün sonunda kendinizle başbaşa
kalıyorsunuz O yüzden başkalarından
motivasyon alabilirsiniz Evet alın o
unutmayın gün sonunda kendinizde siniz O
yüzden kendinize Lütfen iyi davranın
Yani ben mesela eskiye döndüm de eski
Halime bir şey söylemek istesem kendine
lütfen iyi davran bu şu demek isterdim
Çünkü E yani zorlandığınız noktaları
olabiliyor işte başarısız olduğumuz
nokta noktalar olabiliyor yani diyeti
bırakabilirsiniz hedefinizden
şaşırtabilirsiniz ama kendinize Hiçbir
zaman kötü davranmayın çünkü yani
düşünün bir arkadaşınız bir şey
başaramadı zaman ona Siz kötü davranır
mısınız o yapamadın işte sen
başarısızsın dersiniz kendinize demeyin
Hatta bence kendinize çok çok daha iyi
davranın olsun bu sefer yapamadın bir
sonraki ne yaparsın yarın devam edersin
diyin kendinize kendinize arada bir izin
verin Kendinizi çok fazla sıkmayın yani
hedefiniz için bence geçerli zaten bu
söylediklerime kendinizi arada ta oy
verin işte çok çalışıyorsanız arada bir
haftalık 15 günlük tatiller verin
kendinize ya da kendinizi arada
hediyeler alın başka bir arkadaşınıza
belki alırken düşünemeyeceğimiz bir
hediyeyi kendinizi alırken neden 30 kr40
yere düşünesiniz Ben yeteri kadar para
kazanmadım bunu Haketmedim yiyeceğinizi
Abi ben bu ay kendime böyle bir hediye
almak istiyorum deyip kendinizi arada
mutlu etmeniz Bence bütün süreçleri çok
çok daha e kolay ve güzel bir şekilde
elde etmenizi sağlayacaktır Bir de
kendime bir şey daha söylemek isterdim o
da acele etmem gerektiği Yani bence bu
hedefinize yönelik hedefinize yönelerek
ilerlerken
yapılan Bence en büyük hatalardan bir
tanesi acele etmek yani bir şey
yapıyorsunuz Bir hedefimiz var Onunla
ilgili bir şey yapıyorsunuz ve sürekli
kontrol ediyorsunuz olmuş mu Ben MS Ben
her gün tartıya çıkardım her gün aynaya
bakardım yapmak bence çok yanlış Çünkü
zaten Ne yapmanız gerektiğini bildiğiniz
zaman ve o sürece kendinizi adadığını
zaman akışta bir şeyler oluyor yani 21
gün alışkanlığı diye bir şey var İlk
başlarda zor oluyor sonra alışıyorsunuz
sürece be Zaten insanlar sağa ne kadar
kilo vermişsin A ne kadar iyi
görünüyorsun Sen de bir değişim var diye
Böyle yaklaşımlarla bulunduğu zaman
zaten bu ufak ufak size motivasyon
verecektir sizin sürecinize tutmanız da
yardımcı olacaktır diye düşünüyorum ben
kendimi
Aslında bu kadar böyle geliştirirken on
Çaltı hissediyorum ve böyle güzel bir
kitle mi olduğu için Çünkü aslında benim
kitlem de beni motive ediyor ki Tam da
benim kendime bir şeyler katmanız
sağlıyor Yani ben yolun başındayken hiç
bu bu geleceğimi düşünmezdim Başka
insanlara ilham olabilmek Bir Başka
insanlara yardımcı olabilmek mi
söyleseler Muhtemelen inanmazdım ama şu
anda Yani çok çok güzel yerlere
getirdiğini düşünüyorum birçok insanı
ben de fazla kilo verenler oluyor 45
kilo işte 50 kilo verdiğini söyleyenler
oluyor kadınlar erkekler herkese böyle
şöyle altmış kilo Zaten şöyle bir şey
göstereyim 60 kilo veren olmuştu böyle
mesaj atıyorlar Ben de tabii ki bunlarla
bayağı böyle gurur duyuyorum bum Yani bu
süreçle ilgili Başka söylemek istediğim
acele etmemenizi işte Tabii ki bazen
başarısız olabilirsiniz ya başarısız
demek istediğim de şu Sonuçta siz
kendinize bir motivasyon veriyorsunuz
bir sürece giriyorsunuz bir alev alıyor
orada bir şey bu süreçte Yani bu sürece
böyle bir alev alıyor olarak
düşünebilirsiniz bel var Yani bu alev
sönebilir sönmeye yaklaşabilir sizin
yapmanız gereken şey ben şöyle
bağdaştırıcı maslıne da hani küllerinden
doğmak benim için Mesela ne anlam ifade
ediyor diye düşünürsem Aslında benim
için iki anlam ifade ediyor bir tanesi o
ateşin tam sönmeye yaklaştığı noktada
Sizin doğru adımlarla doğru tekniklerle
o Alevi hemen böyle birazcık
ateşlendirmek niz güçlendirme nizde
Bence aslında bir küllerden doğmak
sonuçta orada azalan ateşle bir küller
oluşacak orada ve oküler de bir çok az
kalan o artık hani diyetlerin ya da
şeyini sizin böyle Sonsırma noktanız
yani tutuyorsunuz yapacak yapıyorsunuz
devam ediyorsunuz bakma mısınız Ama hani
artık yapamayacağım bırakacağım Bu falan
dediğiniz noktada doğru şekilde
yaklaşırsanız kendinize doğru
motivasyonu verirseniz kendiniz ve
istikrar sağlayabilirsiniz tekrardan o
ateşi al evlendirebilir ve daha güçlü
olabilirsiniz o ateşi Siz
güçlendirdiğini zaman ne kadar daha
güçlü olacağınızı anlatamam size Yani
ben şu anda kendimi gerçekten çok güçlü
hissediyorum bu sürecin başında kendimi
çok daha zayıf işte yapamayacağım
Başaramayacağım gibi hissederken Şu anda
ben istersem kilo da alırım istersen
hemen veririm de diye biliyorsam bu
küllerin bu ateşin size nasıl güç
verdiğini böyle anlayabilirsiniz bir
tanesi de beni ikinci anlama da bu
küllerinden doğmanın
artık sönmüş yani bırakmışsınız işte
içinden belki üzerinden Belki bir ay
geçmiş bir hafta geçmiş Her neyse Ama
hala da İçinizde bir şey var Yani yapmak
istiyorsunuz tekrardan sarılmak
istiyorsunuz Bu sürece Çünkü bir
hedefimiz var ve vazgeçme misiniz o
hedeften o noktada Bence kendi İyi
seyirler verdiğiniz motivasyon olur
başkasından aldığınız bir ilham olur bir
şey olup oraya tekrardan yeni odun
parçaları koyarak tekrardan
alevlendirmenin ve etrafındaki o Külleri
temizlemeniz de bence çok önemli çünkü
ben o küllere sizin ya da bizim
yaşadığımız tecrübeler olarak bakıyorum
tecrübeler de bu süreçte çok önemli bu
hataları ben yapmıştım bu sefer
yapmayacağım diyerek Devam etmeniz ve
bence çok daha güzel adımlar atmanızı
sağlayacaktır İlla büyük adımlar atmamız
gerekmiyor ufak adımlarla da sonuca
yaklaşabilirsiniz Yani illa bir anda
hayatınızı değiştirmeniz gerekmiyor Fak
değişiklikler yapın yavaş yavaş
ilerleyin hedefinize Hayat gerçekten
uzun Biz gençler şu anda hayatı hızlı
yaşıyoruz ve hedefimize hızlı bir
şekilde ulaşmak istiyoruz ama aslında
çok çok zamanımız var yeter ama
zamanımız olduğuna inanıyorum ben
hedeflerimize ulaşmak için yani kendimi
burada olabildiğince böyle
hissettiklerimi yansıtmak istedim Umarım
yazda bilmişimdir Ben aynı o kabindeki
gibi yaşadığımız her şeyin bir anlamı
olduğunu düşünüyorum yani hiçbir şey
tesadüf değildir Benim için tesadüfler
Tabii ki var ama her şeyde bir anlamı
olduğuna inanıyorum ben Eğer buradaysan
ız beni dinliyorsanız ya da
internetten de izliyorsanız şu anda
bunları duyuyorsunuz Bu sizin için
işaret olabilir düşünün yani kendinizde
bir hedefiniz var mı bilmiyorum ama
hedef belirlemek benim için şu anda
mesela olmazsa olmaz bir şey Hedef
olmadan hedefim olmadan yaşayamam Çünkü
alışmışım birkere kendini Hedef koyarak
ilerleme o yüzden yani hedefimiz var mı
bilmiyorum ama kendinize bir hedef
belirleyebilirsiniz ve o hedefiniz
doğrultusunda artık
her yer yapmaya başlayabilirsiniz Bu da
sizin için belki bir başlangıç
noktasıdır yeni yıla girmeden önce
kendinize bir şeyler katmak için doğru
zaman olabilir Umarım kendimi güzel bir
şekilde aktarabilme şimdi
hissettiklerimi yaşadıklarımı ve
duygularımı ev beni dinlediğiniz için
çok teşekkür ediyorum